racism it's everywhere racists are
everywhere they're coming for you
you thought we conquered racism well
it's back baby and now it's cool uh
western washington university this is
from fox news
they've designated the fourth floor of
alma clark glass all as housing reserved
for its black affinity housing program
becoming the latest school to adopt such
a program the university hosted a
webinar in april on the subject saying
the segregated living space gives the
students to the opportunity to live in a
shared space with others who have a
shared identity specifically a
marginalized identity the controversial
program segregating student housing
based on race has been adopted at some
other colleges including the university
of colorado at boulder stanford
university and cornell university so i
don't think we have to belabor the point
here
the people who purport to be the
anti-racists the people who are for
diversity and inclusion are actually
for discrimination and exclusion the
idea that we would send
young people our future leaders to
colleges where they should segregate
themselves where they should do the
reverse of what the civil rights
movement
was all about that they should only be
around black people if they're black
thus only allowing white people to be
around white people right if you keep
telling all the black kids hey you got
your own thing over there well then
you're going to suddenly have a white
dorm do we want a white dorm wouldn't
that be racist and by the way if you
just play all this stuff out if you just
play this out over 10 20 years and we
keep
having diversity inclusion programs and
it keeps getting easier to hire people
or you have to hire people because
they're gay or black or have a limp or
whatever it might be
do you think at some point then the
average just decent kid who happens to
be say a straight white christian male
do you think that then would start
counting as discrimination against him
and then should he start getting
benefits do you see why this would take
us on the road to hell but this is what
these people have brought it's really
quite insane and i hope that most of you
if you're watching this and you're in
college you would not
partake in such a program but i think
the bigger issue is that
once again what are the answers like
what's the answer if we just talk about
this okay so now you're watching this
and you're going boy that's that's
pretty racist and that's pretty stupid
and all that stuff and i won't send my
kids there but that's kind of not enough
and it's not enough for me to just talk
about it what would be enough is that we
must be building new things let's be
building new education systems let's let
cornell be racist let's let stanford be
racist we can't stop them they want the
institutions they got the institutions
they got basically all of them so let
them have them
build continue to build all your crappy
things continue to bring in students not
based on skill but on these immutable
characteristics which will ultimately
destroy the academic level of your
system of your school and then the rest
of us will hopefully build new
businesses and new schools and new
technology companies and all of that
stuff i know i know i know this is white
supremacist stuff you know i'm saying
that white people and black people and
gay people and straight people
asian people jew and gentile should all
be in the same dorm together you know
thus white supremacy